cos'altro mi dovrei aspettare ben
attenti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovo intelligentissimo video molto
probabilmente sono fuori j e faccio
giochi intelligenti ma ci siamo
[Musica]
va beh meglio forse andare su play e
godersi questa questa questa perla tra e
moving al houdry bene bene bene lo vedo
un gioco tattico molto semplice è una
specie di super hot solo con un po più
di rag doll
ecco super 8 e vabbè vabbè ragazzi
matrix ma bellissimo dream it to be all
and jump and replay slow motion jumping
stormwind or to go to the next level ai
tipo crash bandicoot entri nei livelli
così ho anche supermario era bene
ragazzi mi sembra una genialata sta roba
non so se ci arrivo ti prego tutto a
posto
riproviamoci ragazzi allora questo
attraversato york madonna come lo schiva
peccato perché questa me la meritavo è
perché aveva mostrato la macchina di
prima ma dai
sono tirato solo una testata ragazza è
attestata non è niente cava ornava per
ragazzi ma è bellissimo
ho fatto una ho fatto delle trovate
assurde l'altro si vede la stessa mappa
in sala lontano c'è tutto un triplo
gioco devi veramente parti di altre cose
veri giornalista non c'è un robottino
carinissimo anche cosa serva sta roba ma
nel dubbio penso sia un nemico entrava
dentro per adesso ragazzi è tutto a
posto mi sta piacendo ed è un gioco
molto tranquillo e easy molto più
intelligente dei giochi che faccio di
solito comunque complimenti ma le armi
esattamente quando iniziamo utilizzarle
perché finora non ho sparato niente cioè
ci sono le armi che li usiamo le ragazze
mi sembra uno spreco capito
salve non sò se lei ecco appunto non so
se le lei è un nemico lo vedo dalla
faccia
è la madonna siamo tutti calmi però
credo che questo sia tipo è un tipo long
as sto gioco senza e le persone con
molto rag doll senza l'anti senza lo
spazio ovviamente non c'entra un cazzo
allora allora ce l'ho fatta sono beason
schiantato sulla porta ma ce l'ho fatta
a posto
non so come si non entra ce l'ho fatta
ce l'ha fatta
meraviglioso non fate domande perché non
saprei darmi risposte però ok sono tutto
snodato non mi avrete e vabbè senza
guardare anche un fenomeno non solo che
sto andando ma fa niente
oddio c'è una imboscata imboscata ce
l'ho fatta
non ce l'ho con una fatta attenzione
ancora vivo ma era spara perfetto action
ce n'è ancora uno li ecco perché morte
morte morto let's go meraviglioso non
fate domande ma ce la sto facendo
ragazzi da lontano proci jolo
ma come luci vi sono caduti in testa è
veramente passato questo progetti sono
caduti in faccia la cosa attento non
abbracciare le travi di legno o prova
arrivare dall'altra parte anche se
dubito di riuscire anche perché quella
un certo punto inizia a spararmi ma gli
sparo prima io
perfetto dove vado e come forti night ha
letto tutto ok
devo andare
slide mirror's edge
ma cosa ma cosa ti prego e vabbè gioco
veramente della e come ho fatto a non
scoprire prima st perla ok credo di
essere arrivato al tutto in questo gioco
somiglia veramente un sacco fall guys
però la prima parte l'ho superata che
già miracolo c'è gente c'è gente farà
perfetto l'altro nei posti dove sto
andando c'è scritto al latte altra roba
cioè spiega mi chiedo cosa chiacchio
vendi come perciò salirla ecco niente a
portare che male mi stava pure facendo
questo qua mannaggia a lui non ho capito
ragazzi si è dentro le case c'è qualcosa
ma non sto dicendo la spaccata e mi chi
se ne frega del gioco molto intelligente
questo comunque secondo me ragazzi se mi
faccio sparare direttamente sul tailleur
ii scopro vediamo
non prometto niente ma ci provo non ci
voglio credere
vabbè vabbè vabbè penso di aver fatto il
record diventato 9 sushana posso mettere
su youtube non si può mettere poi è
diventato come si chiamava quel gioco
del dove dove trapianto vi saltare da un
camion e all'altro tipo cluster tra che
la roba del genere sempre ai creatori di
super 8 comunque allora quanto deve
essere difficile arrivare sullo
decapitato questo non sarà che avevo
fatto
minchia stavo svenendo sul finale ma poi
ma poi ce l'ho fatta quello perfetto
puoi entrare questo livello è stata
un'agonia
oddio cosa vi è ma prevale ma cosa mi
rappresenta sta roba credo che questo
livello ragazzi sia l'ultimo non lo so
perché penso sia infattibile cioè sta
roba è veramente fuori e vabbè allora
fai dubai dove vuoi
penso sia oltre ogni aspettativa umana
mi fate vedere un attimo nel menu quanta
roba c'è
a me da 15 nel menu questo possiamo
saltare questo che grazie siamo arrivati
al termine della strada quello che ho
scattato la gala che si comincia farò
mai aveva bad guys and coworkers
addirittura due pistole
oddio adesso è diventato anche un po my
friends pedro non so se lo ricordate
c'è questo poi era veramente molto più
semplice di voi prima se perdente ma
proprio di mille evolve thank you man 4
livelli to go eva per la cappa la
chiappa 47 giusto per rendere un po più
tamarro sto gioco come se non lo fosse
abbastanza
quand'è che dovrei saltare esattamente
tipo adesso sparami faramir madonna
madonna perfetto no
salve e va perché ho fatto
vabbè aspetta che cuoce nell'arte lo
prendo ok allora a posto devo andare di
sopra quindi ma dov'è il casinò a dodo
arriva no pasta si basta assi vi prego
ski pettino a questo punto però la trave
si è messa di mezzo facciamo il 14 che
mi sono un po più stile minecraft ma
cosa devo fare sti cosi come propulsione
non ve lo faccio di mettere insieme
madonna e vabbè un attimo oltre alle
aspettative e fin qua ok non si sposare
la propulsione propulsione beh ma un
attimo più contenuto per cortesia
ok ok ok
limite se mi devasta e figure di merda
primo livello
ragazzi questo era ma come diavolo si
giocano qualcosa come sono i ragazzi se
vi è piaciuto lasciato momento è un bel
mi piace
fatemi sapere il senso di questo gioco
nei commenti lo saprete più di me
niente noi ci vediamo come sempre al
prossimo video un po più intelligente
magari va beh beh ragazzi
[Musica]